d'impressionnantes bâtissant cap là de
simples planches est en pin des landes
la maison de l'environnement à magny les
hameaux a proposé aux enfants pendant
les vacances
un atelier de construction avec ses
pièces animé par le centre capela de
paris l'atelier a invité également les
parents à participer tour eiffel trains
maisons l'architecturé est adapté à tous
les âges
on en reste à une base et on les guide
au fur à mesure notre écho début ils
savent pas trop vim après ce qui est
pratique c'est qu'une fois qui a déjà
des constructions il voit et ils ont
envie aussi de réaliser des choses aussi
impressionnante que les autres à partir
de là ça les motive plus de 22000
plancher en bois étaient à la
disposition des enfants le kapla fait
appel aussi bien à la logique quelle
imagination parents et grands parents
n'ont pas hésité à emmener les enfants à
l'atelier pour l'accompagner pendant
cette découverte d'une nouvelle activité
surtout thomas d'utiliser le bois voilà
ce qui était intéressant de voir cet
atelier ludique à développer la
réflexion et la dextérité manuelle des
enfants il a permis également de
peut-être susciter des vocations de
bâtisseur j'aime bien la construction
qu'est ce que tu aimerais construire
va des trucs hauts des bas des trucs
qu'on peut faire c'est pas quoi
et l'occasion pour lés parents de
partager un moment de loisir avec leurs
enfants et aussi de se prendre au jeu